what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i'm going
to be talking about
um common mistakes i see women make in
dating and i'm going to be analyzing a
girl that i saw on tick tock i mean just
some mistakes that i think
i've seen her make i've seen a lot of
girls make it i don't always necessarily
think
girls realize that they're making them
um before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and ring that
notification
bell that way you're going to be
notified of my daily videos
okay and just before i start um this is
nothing against her
and this is literally just my opinion so
you guys can you know take this with a
great assault
um but one thing okay
let me give you an overview of who she
is who she is
so serena carrington started a dating
show
called let's let's um
let's effing date and the whole premise
of the
show was she dated like 50 guys on
instagram live
um and then ended up with one guy at the
end that was supposed to like
she was going to date him or whatever um
and i'm just going to show you her like
persona
on tick tock and instagram so
she'll post something right now and it's
a tuesday
yeah at 8 am to work out and do a photo
and video shoot
and i didn't want to say no
to the date because
because i don't want to say it with a
[ __ ] date and also because like what
like i have to i have to date like
that's fun
i oh my god sorry what i meant to say is
that like
i don't want to make my entire life
about my work i want to enjoy i want to
meet people i want to [ __ ] like or hook
up or nothing
nothing at all i'm going to regard i'm
not going to post this anyway um
but the issue is is that like is it how
do you go on a date without drinking
like it feels stigmatized like if i was
just be like no it's kind of water like
there's
it just makes it weird it actually it
doesn't matter and that's
that's unfortunate sorry it actually
doesn't make it weird if you go on a
date without drinking
i actually find it really attractive
when the other person says oh i don't
drink
um just me though i don't know but she
posts a lot about just like going out to
bars drinking casual hookups
like this one you applied first for the
defense against the dark arts post is
that correct
yes but you were unsuccessful
so you know stuff about like coming um
sex
going out you know the party life
basically um
and here's the thing that i don't think
a lot of girls realize
the messaging you're putting out
are you looking for sexual attention or
wifey attention
um i'm gonna give you guys an example of
a good and a bad post that i see on her
instagram so like this
do you guys want to marry this girl do
you want to ask this girl
typically let me go look at a different
one
did i do the screen share yeah i did
okay um
like this let's date our exes are
watching so this message
says i'm not over my ex because i
clearly
care what he thinks um like this one
sexual attention wifey attention i'm
gonna find one i saw a picture that i
like to purse
like this is this is a beautiful picture
right here
and i think this right here signals wife
attention
wife attention you know but this is the
thing i think a lot of girls don't
realize you'll see those girls that get
that attention on social media
and you know i think girls in general
are competitive
and you know they i think girls tend to
want attention from men
and so you'll think you're getting the
attention that you want but you don't
end up in a relationship
um okay so what's one
question you hate being asked
do you think that you're still single
because like guys find you intimidating
all right so do you think you're still
single because guys find you
intimidating am i intimidated
intimidating or are they just insecure
um so i don't really like
that narrative because that's
insinuating that something is wrong with
all the guys and nothing could possibly
be wrong with you
um and i know a lot of girls don't want
to hear this because
you know we're always told be confident
be confident be confident but
if guys are saying something
like oh they just find you intimidating
but that's not it
i'm telling you we're victorious
victoria's secret models could be very
intimidating but they never
have trouble finding people to date and
i know girls like this will always say
oh i don't need a man like i don't want
to be in a relationship or need to be
but then they'll post things like this
because you're idealizing what could
have been
so she's talking about why is it so hard
to get over a guy you never even dated
so you have this whole fantasy of like
well if we were together
and honestly like there's a reason
you're not together that's the universe
being like no [ __ ] hold my wine i have
something better for you okay [ __ ]
so um move the [ __ ] on and you know
that's not bad advice like
obviously you should move on you
shouldn't
lose sleep over someone you never dated
but the question is why are you in that
situation
to begin with you shouldn't be in that
situation
um and
you can tell that clearly it didn't work
out well for her like
that had happened at some point or for
the girl like watch
because you're idealizing what could
have been like why are you idealizing
what could have been if you don't need a
man or want a relationship
yeah double homicide so when he comes
inside of you and doesn't pay for plan b
and i get it it's like supposed to be
comedic and a funny tic-tac but guys you
have to realize
what messaging you're sending out to
guys
so you're saying
when he comes inside of you and doesn't
play for pan plan b
this is the message this is the ex the
behavior
that i accept
like now again what kind of attention is
this gonna be i guarantee her audience
is female because this type of stuff
grosses guys out
it just does um
i started a viral dating show and i
dated 50 men over the course of a year
so that's why when it comes to dating i
know what the [ __ ] i'm doing
even though i'm still single i never
said i was good at relationships i said
i'm good at dating
this card game will change your [ __ ]
life if you're feeling nervous on a date
buy this card game you're trying to get
laid okay whatever she's
trying to sell a card game but you know
same thing she's good at dating not good
at relationships and the question is why
and
anybody who looks at her social media
for like
five seconds could clearly see why
and you know i genuinely feel bad for
women like this because
i i genuinely think they've been given
the wrong messaging and even in her
dating show like there seemed to be nice
guys that
were genuinely interested in every all
the music platforms and everything let's
go
i know you're going to want to hang out
with me hang up we're going to be like
is he any good at this guy
and then she chooses the basically the
most attractive guy with an accent
um that clearly was just i hate to say
it but out of her league
wait let me go over here
this guy so you know
uh like a real ending wait where'd it go
um i can't find it but guys you have to
take my word like this guy
and the same girls that'll say no one's
out of your league no one's out of your
league no one's out of
your league are the same girls that'll
say
you're or you're out of his league
like guys everyone has a league and it's
totally okay she's an attractive girl
but it's like she probably missed out on
guys that actually wanted to date her
by going for the tens that's just what
girls always do
um what else
oh my gosh sorry guys i'm kind of sick
they say no press is bad pressed right
well the new york post
interviewing me about how much sex i'm
having this summer is truly a highlight
of my my career and i quote this summer
is about having a lot of sex
everyone's getting vaccinated everyone's
horny and everyone's sick of virtual
dating oh how proud my parents must be
about this one but on the real
this is the summer [ __ ] not giving a
[ __ ] doing things that [ __ ] and
[ __ ] a lot so go get faxed and then
waxed
clean up those closets and cut off those
relationships that are no longer serving
you because the whoring 20s are here
[ __ ] and it's gonna [ __ ]
hard god that crit that's so cringy
like guys ladies
what type of attention like what
messaging are you sending out
i have casual sex i am okay with casual
sex and i'm going to have casual sex so
then in your dms what type of guys are
going to be messaging you
like really think about it and you know
i bet deep down this girl wants
relationships and wants to be like who
doesn't want to be in a happy healthy
relationship
but a lot of girls get in their own way
and i feel bad for them honestly like
that guy you just [ __ ] and you won't
return your text but it doesn't matter
you know why because you smell just like
if you're not using this deodorant
you're making a huge mistake
smells like that guy you just [ __ ]
anyone okay
um so again
and i don't look at maybe
i could be wrong but my intuition says
that this isn't going to lead to happy
healthy relationships i could be wrong
you know but
ladies ladies come on we can do better
we can do better than this
oh this is the other one you know like
it's i mean it's a tough show to do with
the instagram live dating so
how many straight men are going to want
to do that with me on the other
receiving end
i'm amazing but i'm tough so um you know
you have to be super [ __ ] confident
and really give no [ __ ] which like
it's it's a tough sell so i but that
wasn't really you know ultimately the
point of the show i mean in the
beginning it was it was too many people
that i did like i did it i've been on
dates in real life with a lot of the
guys from the show are staying really
good friends
on instagram still so you know that to
me was important to show that like we
determined this is what we say like the
point of dating is to have fun and meet
people
and that's fine if you want to have fun
and meet people but at the end of the
day
like i don't want to waste my time
without an end goal like and it's always
the most career-driven women that
really see the value and not wasting
time and getting things done but when it
comes to getting married and having kids
they don't seem to even put that on the
radar until it's too late
and a lot of times these women end up
like single
and by themselves
so i don't know just my two cents
um i really think we should talk more
about the difference between like sexual
attention
and relationship attention because girls
you know i want to just go through
instagram look at
sexual attention
sexual attention you can see she has the
melons up there
uh having trouble finding a good one
um
i think this is cute relationship
attention i don't like the outfit but
i don't know this is just my two cents
though let me know in the comments if
you guys agree
or you disagree don't do not forget to
subscribe to the channel
bring that notification bell that way
you're going to be notified of my daily
videos
and i will talk to you guys next time